The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: You get your
quizzes back on Monday.
Maybe you've had some
time to think about them
and reflect on your
answers and the problems
that were posed, maybe how they
compared to the quiz that--
sample quiz that was put online.
I think it was pretty
fair exam overall.
It looked very similar,
actually, to the exam
that we've given in the
past, but we tried to--
tried not to put any sort of
chemical engineering problems
on top of the
numerics, which tends
to lead to confusion basically.
Spent a lot of time
reading and trying
to understand what the
underlying physical problem is
instead of just testing
the numerical methods.
Are there any questions
about the quiz
now that you've gotten it back?
You've seen your answers,
things that were unclear that
were asked on there?
Now is a good time for
reflection if there are.
No.
I heard this last homework
assignment was really long, so
sorry about that.
I didn't write this one.
[LAUGHS]
I'm not going to
Take credit for it.
It's hard to judge sometimes
how long these things take.
A lot of it has to do with how
facile you are with coding up
some of the problems.
So conceptually
they can be simple,
but the coding can
be quite difficult,
so it's hard to estimate.
I think this week's,
which should be posted
and is on the topic of
DAE, should be easier.
It's only got two
problems instead of three.
You're likely going
to be able to leverage
some of the code
from your solution
last week for this week.
So I don't think it should
be quite so challenging.
There is a last part
to the first problem
that seems to always
give first-year graduate
students trouble.
Somehow you guys don't
know how to write down
energy balances on reactors.
So you might ask
pointed questions
about this at your office hours,
so you don't spend time trying
to solve the wrong equations.
This happens.
I think many of you maybe were
taught incorrectly or just
forgot at some point how
to write these things down.
So the office hour is a
good point to bring that up,
and that way you don't
spend a lot of time
troubling yourself with the
wrong system of equations.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
I'd-- well, to be fair, almost
all the lectures for the rest
of the class are going to be
taught by Professor Green.
I'll step in and do some
review for two sessions,
review before the second quiz
and review before the final.
Since he's leading
the lectures, he'll
be responsible for largely
generating the homework
assignments.
I'll try to help out
with that as best I can,
but this will be the
last formal lecture
you get from me this term.
Other questions?
Well, that's very,
very sweet of you.
Thank you so much.
Least there wasn't
any hushed yes!
Today's lecture is
our last one on DAE,
so we're only going to do two.
You're going to see today
that differential algebraic
equations are pretty
complicated actually.
And when they get
sufficiently complicated,
you really need to reach
out to existing codes that
are designed to solve particular
classes of differential
algebraic equations.
So for you, it's
more important to be
able to identify in the
models you formulate when
these complications
arise and what
are the essential
ingredients of the model that
can be put into one
of these solvers
that you get a result
that isn't nonsense.
And that's what we're
going to do today.
There's going to be lots of
examples to work through.
So make sure you're
sitting next to somebody
you like because I'm
going to ask you to try
to think about these
things and discuss things
as we go through.
Let me review where these
complications come from.
So last time we talked
briefly about semi-explicit
and fully-implicit differential
algebraic equations.
I told you in principle, you
could simulate these things
with backwards
difference formulas
in solving nonlinear
equations at each time step
and just marching forward.
Did this in your
homework for ODE IVP
So you can do the same thing
for differential algebraic
equations.
But there was a catch to
that, and I illustrated that
at the very end.
So maybe your brain was fried
at the end, and you missed this.
It's good to recap.
So I showed you an
example of a stirred tank
where you had some--
you had transport of some
solute into the stirred tank,
and then you're pulling it out
at a different concentration.
And we're trying to track
the dynamics of the system,
the concentration in and
the concentration out,
and we imagined a
problem in which
we measured and the
concentration in
and we tried to predict
the concentration out.
So we had a system of
differential and algebraic
equations to solve.
And I showed you that if I
used the backward Euler method,
the lowest order backwards
difference formula that I can--
of the canonical
class of these things
that I can craft, where I
approximate the derivative
of an unknown with a relative
error or an error proportional
to the time step delta t,
that carrying out one time
step with this backward
differentiation formula
would determine c1 in
principle exactly--
if I knew gamma exactly,
I would know c1 exactly.
And it would determine c2 to
within order delta t-squared.
It's the local truncation error
here was order delta t-squared.
So you just substitute
this formula in,
and you ask does this
error term change at all.
At some point, I wind up
multiplying by delta t,
and so I go from order delta t
to order delta t-squared It's
the numerical error
that gets carried around
in this calculation.
I just switch the
model a little bit.
It seems like a
irrelevant change,
but it turns out to be
incredibly significant.
So now I imagine a
different problem
in which I'm measuring
c2 the outlet,
and I want to
predict c1 the inlet.
I still have a system of
DAEs that I have to solve,
and if I applied the
backwards Euler method,
well, c2 is
automatically determined
by this algebraic equation.
So I know that exactly.
I got to go up to this first
equation and solve it for c1,
and when I do, I have
to have an approximation
for the derivative.
And the derivative is
proportional to delta t--
carries an error around with it
that's proportional to delta t.
So I know c1 to within order
delta t, not order delta
t-squared like in
the previous model.
So there's something
fundamentally different
about these two circumstances.
And all I did was go from c1 to
c2 in this algebraic equation.
So that's peculiar,
and that should
make you really suspicious
about your ability
to solve these
problems accurately.
And here was the third
example I gave you.
So I said imagine this
system of DAEs instead.
So here's the
differential equation.
Here's an algebraic equation.
Apply the backward Euler method.
Well, c3 is determined
automatically
by this algebraic equation.
I know it exactly.
C2 is related to the
derivative of c3,
so I need to approximate it with
my backward Euler derivative.
And that picks up an
error, order delta t.
C1 is equal to the
derivative of c2,
so I need an
approximation for c2.
The derivative of c2 that's the
backwards Euler approximation.
That has an error that's
proportional to order delta t.
But c2 itself also has an error
And order delta t divided
by delta t is order 1.
So I get c3.
I get c2.
I even know what c1 is.
I solve this problem with my
backwards difference formula,
and I have no resolution of
c1, no clue what that value is.
So this is some
complicated control scheme
that I've set up, and I
need to know the value of c1
to figure out how to
operate this process.
I'm lost.
This is never going to work.
So these three problems
have fundamental differences
between them.
And I'm going to show
you how to predict
when these differences are going
to occur, how to name them.
So the stirred
tank example 1, it
carried a local truncation
error, one time step order
delta-t squared.
Stirred tank example 2 carried
a local truncation error.
It's order delta-t.
This third DAE example had
a local truncation error
that's order 1.
No change in delta-t
will improve my solution
to that problem.
It's independent of how I choose
to do my time setting, which,
of course, is ridiculous.
So here's another problem.
And I'd like you
to try to do this.
We'll see how far you
can get through it.
You don't have to get
all the way through it,
but see how far you can
get through this problem.
So can you apply the
backward Euler method
to this system of DAEs
and try to predict how
the air propagates.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK, I don't want to break up
the conversation too much,
but tell me what you're
finding as you try to do this.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: We found
that c3 has to be 0.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How did you find
that c3 has to be 0?
AUDIENCE: Stick in
this [INAUDIBLE]
that's what the difference
is of the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
PROFESSOR: OK, so
this is very clever,
and this has to do with how
the model itself is formulated.
So you did manipulations with
the fundamental equations
that I wrote down to
determine that c3 had to be 0.
That's good.
We can do that.
We can look at the equations.
We can figure how to eliminate
variables and find out--
c3 in this case
always has to be 0.
That may or may not be
obvious, but one way to do it
is take this constraint equation
and take its derivative.
This has to hold at
every point in time,
so its derivative must hold
at every point in time.
Substitute these
other two equations
in, c1 dot plus c2 dot
eliminates c1 and c2,
and all that will be
left is c3 has to be 0.
So if I manipulate
these equations,
I know c3 has to be 0.
Let's suppose I don't manipulate
the equations, though.
Let's suppose I just put in the
backward Euler approximation
over here for the
derivative, and I
evaluate c1, c2 and
c3 at the current time
and ask what is c1, c2, and c3
at the current time in terms
of what it was at
the previous time
And you get an answer
that looks like this.
So there's a simple
system of equations
that one has to solve.
It's a three-by-three system,
and it's easy to eliminate.
I didn't really expect you--
actually expected
this answer to come up
because you guys
are all very clever,
so you try to make
things easy beforehand.
But it's-- there's
a problem here.
If I try to just do the
backwards difference
formula with the equations
as they're written,
I'll find out that
when I solve this thing
that c1 will be c1 minus c2 at
the previous time step over 2
plus an order delta
t-squared error.
C2 will take on the opposite
sign plus an order delta
t-squared error.
C3 will be minus c1
plus c2 over 2 delta t
plus an order delta t error.
And actually if I were to apply
successive approximations,
different-- if I step--
take many steps in a row with
this backward Euler method,
there's nothing to guarantee
that these constraints are
satisfied exactly.
I can have numerical
error in my solution
of this algebraic equation.
So it isn't necessarily true
that in my numerical solution
c1 plus c2 is equal to 0.
I can show you right
here if I add c1 to c2.
Well, these two are the same.
They'll cancel, but am I
guaranteed that these errors
will cancel, too?
Or will there be a
small numerical error
that propagates?
So model formulation is key.
This problem is like
stirred tank problem 2.
One of our solutions
lost in order of accuracy
in the local truncation error.
It's not delta t-squared.
It's order delta t.
And what you want it to do,
which is not necessarily
a bad thing, was to try
to use this constraint
to somehow eliminate
equations and simplify things.
That can be helpful,
but it can also
be true that if I use this
constraint to simplify
equations and eliminate
things, my numerical solutions
may no longer satisfy
the constraint at all.
They may drift away from
that algebraic equation.
Does that makes sense?
I'm not controlling the error
with respect to that equation
anymore.
So how do you give a name
to this kind of behavior?
And the thing one talks about
is the differential index
of a DAE system.
So let's look at the
stirred tank example 1,
and let's ask this question.
How many time
derivatives are needed
to convert to a system of
independent ODEs having
differentials of
all the unknowns.
So there are two
unknowns in this system.
One is c1, and the other c2.
Actually have one
equation, which
contains a differential of c2.
How many derivatives of
these equations with time
do I need to take in order to
get an equivalent ODE system?
And it's just one.
If I take the derivative
of equation 2,
I'll get a differential
equation for c1.
Now, I have a differential
equation for c1
and a differential
equation for c2.
DAEs of this type,
where I only have
to take the time derivative once
of the algebraic constraints,
are called index 1 DAEs.
We saw that when we applied
the backwards difference
formula to stirred
tank example 1,
the local truncation error
was the same as what we
would get in an ODE IVP system.
So index 1--
DAEs are easy to solve.
They behave like ODE IVPs.
You determine whether
it's index 1 or not
by asking how many
derivatives do
I have to take in order to get
a system of independent ODEs.
So I put this
together with this,
I have two independent ODEs.
I could solve these, subject to
some set of initial conditions,
and the solution
might be the same
as the solution to the DAE.
Let's do stirred
tank example 2 now.
So here we go.
They look very
similar, but now c2
appears in the algebraic
equation instead of c1.
So let's take a derivative
of the algebraic equation,
and I get a differential
equation for c2.
But I already had a
differential equation for c2.
I want a differential
equation for c1.
So what do I do?
While I know dc2
dt from up here.
So let's substitute that
in and solve for c1.
So a substitute
equation 1 in here.
I solve for c1.
Now, let's take
another derivative.
Call this equation 3.
Derivative of equation
3 now gives me
a differential equation for c1.
It's also in terms of dc2 dt.
If I want--
I don't have to--
but if I want to,
I can substitute for
that again to just get
dc1 dt in terms of c1 and c2.
But it took two
derivatives to generate
a system of independent
ODEs from the DAEs.
And this is called index 2.
So it's a different
character from index 1.
We saw what happens.
We tend to lose an order
of accuracy at index 2.
Somehow index 2 problems are
more sensitive than index 1
problems.
Here's another example.
So DAE sample 3 is going
to proceed the same way.
So first we need a
differential equation.
Which one's missing here?
We don't have differential
equation for c1,
and that's what
we're hunting for.
So let's take a derivative
of the third equation,
the algebraic equation.
We get c3 dot is gamma dot.
And we already have an
equation for c3 dot.
That was 2.
So substitute 2 in.
So now we got c2 is gamma
dot, but we're really
looking for something
in terms of c1,
so let's take the
derivative again.
We've got c2 [? dot ?]
is gamma dot dot.
Doesn't help us much, but c2
dot we know is equal to c1.
So we substitute one more time
and take a third derivative.
Now, we have a differential
equation for c1.
And we have differential
equations for c2 and c3.
We can take this is the
differential equation for c3.
This is the differential
equation for c2.
equation for c1.
Some subset of
these can be chosen,
and we can replace
this algebraic equation
with a differential equation.
This is an index 3 DAE.
It's not always a good
idea to replace the DAE
system with these derivatives.
I can write down--
I can have a particular
function that's equal to 0
and higher-order
derivatives of that function
are also equal to 0.
But the solution to those
differential equations
are not necessarily
equal to that function.
There are lots of functions that
might have this same property
that its derivative-- certain
number of derivatives of it
are equal to 0.
So there have to be
extra initial conditions
or constraints on
the solution that
confine me to the
manifold of solutions
that reflects the DAEs.
We'll talk about consistent
initialization later on.
And that's going to
fix this problem.
So it's not always a
good idea to do this,
but it's one way
of understanding,
given this model, what sort of
sensitivity is it can exhibit.
We try to calculate
its differential index.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, we
have to be careful.
We need to choose a set that
are independent of the others.
OK.
So like these three are clearly
going to be independent,
and it's going to be OK.
It's going to be a problem if I
choose this one and these two.
They're not going to be
independent of each other.
So we have to select
independent ones from the set.
It may not be obvious what
independent means in general.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 1, 2, 6
could also work, yes.
Yes.
So in general-- not in general.
Let's talk about the
differential index
of a semi-explicit DAE system.
Remember semi-explicit meant
that the differential variables
can be written as
x dot or dx dt is
equal to some
function of x and y.
Y are the algebraic
states, and they
satisfy a separate equation, g
of x and y and t is equal to 0.
Semi-explicit form.
So with a semi-explicit
DAE, the differential index
is defined as the minimum
number of differentiations
required to convert the DAE to
a system of independent ODEs.
What does that mean?
Means let's take the
algebraic equations
and let's take a time
derivative of them.
That will give us
a new function.
Call it g1.
It's going to be a function
of the differential
state, the algebraic state,
and the time derivative
of the algebraic state.
It could also be a
function of the time
derivative of the
differential state,
but we know that in terms of f,
which is a function of x and y.
So let's not try putting x
dot in there for convenience.
Let's just write out like this.
In principle, we can do this.
Let's take two
derivatives of it.
It will be the same way.
It'll give us some
function g2, which
is a function of
the differential
state, the algebraic state,
and the time derivative
of the algebraic state.
Let's take as many
of these as we need.
It will give us a
system of equations
that we can eventually solve
for the time derivatives of all
the algebraic states and convert
this DAE to a system of ODEs.
And the question is how
many of these derivatives
do I have to take?
Index 1, I need to take one.
Index 2, I need both
sets of equations
in order to get something that
I can actually solve for dy dt.
Index 3, I get to take three
derivatives and higher.
OK, so here's an example.
Let's see if we can
work through this.
So we have a DAE system.
Can you calculate the
differential index
of this system?
Go ahead.
Not 0.
ODE IVP is-- are
DAEs of index 0.
They require no
derivatives to generate
a system of ordinary
differential equations.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Index 2 you say.
How do you come to index 2?
Why is it index 2?
How'd you do it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, differentiate
the algebraic equation.
AUDIENCE: Stick it
in [INAUDIBLE] 4.
You get c3 for 0.
Then you have to
differentiate [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good so
differentiate this equation.
Substitute for c1
dot and c2 dot.
C1 minus c1 will be 0
c2 minus c2 will be 0.
So you have 2c3 equals 0.
That's still an
algebraic equation.
We need one more derivative
to get a differential equation
for the only algebraic
state we have, c3.
So one more derivative
will tell us dc3 dt is 0.
So two derivatives to get
differential equations.
It's an 2 to DAE.
Sam?
SAM: What if you
can get c3 equals 0
and just eliminate
it then wouldn't you
write an equivalent some simple
equations, but that would be
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You could.
So we could write
an equivalent system
of equations that says
instead of this equation,
report c3 equals 0.
That's model formulation.
Here we've given--
we're given a model,
and we're asked
what index it is.
We could formulate
a different model,
and the model will
have a different index.
If I were to replace this
equation with c3 equals 0,
what would the index of
the DAE system be instead?
Index 1 instead.
I already told you index 2 is
harder to solve than index 1,
so if you can formulate
an index 1 DAE,
you should probably do it.
But it may not be obvious
whether you have or haven't.
So it's an issue of
model formulation.
It's a great question.
Does that distinction--
is that clear?
Or is it a little--
am I not making it
clear how this works?
Unresponsive.
OK.
It's OK.
Let's-- there's a generic index
1 example that we can talk
about actually.
So let's take a look at a
semi-explicit DAE system.
So we have x dot is f of xy
and t and 0 is g of xy and t.
Let's take the time derivative
of the algebraic equation.
So the total derivative
of g with respect to t
is the Jacobian
of g with respect
to x times dx dt plus
the Jacobian of g
with respect to y times dy
dt plus the derivative of g--
partial derivative of
g with respect to t.
And now let's solve.
Let's push the dy dt term to
the other side of the equation,
and let's substitute for dx dt.
We know dx dt is f, so you
get this equation here.
If the Jacobian is full rank--
if dg dy is full rank, then
I can invert this matrix,
and I automatically
get my system of ODEs
for the algebraic states.
What's problematic
about this equation
when dg dy is not full rank?
That should be a partial.
That's sloppy.
I was doing this
at 1:00 last night,
so that's why that's there.
What's the-- what's problematic
about this root finding problem
here if dg dy or the Jacobian
of g with respect to y
is not full rank?
You recall?
If--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes, you won't be
able to compute the inverse
to get your dy dt's.
That's true.
Remember this Jacobian--
if it's not full rank,
it's determinant is 0.
There is no inverse
of this thing.
We talked once about the
systems of nonlinear equations
and locally unique solutions,
the so-called inverse function
theorem.
We can only guarantee there is
a locally unique solution when
I can invert this thing.
That if I got in really
close to the solution,
it looked like a linear
system of equations.
That linear system of
equations had a unique solution
associated within.
And everything was good.
We were happy.
So index 1 DAEs
have that property.
If I wanted to solve
this equation for y,
there will be a locally
unique solution for y.
Higher index DAEs don't
have that property.
We know that's a sort of
unhappy generic circumstance
to be in if we have to
solve this equation.
It can be hard to find
those roots using,
say, Newton-Raphson because
the Jacobian [? e ?]
would need to become singular
during the root finding
procedure.
This is connected
intimately to what
we did for systems of
nonlinear equations.
So for an index 1 DAE,
you can show its index
1 because this
Jacobian is invertible.
Let's do some more examples
on differential index.
This seems to be the
most important thing.
If I have a model,
what's its index
because its index is going
to tell me how sensitive it
is to small perturbations.
So here's a model.
It's the same as the
model you saw before,
but now it's two mixing tanks.
So here comes an inlet flow
q1 carrying concentration c1.
Out comes the same flow q1
carrying concentration c2.
The mixer has volume v1.
And then I blend
this with some more
of whatever the solute
is at a flow rate of q2
and a concentration c3.
And those both go
into this tank,
and they come out concentration
c4, flow rate q1 plus q2,
and this has volume v2.
Does that look good?
Well-posed model?
OK, so here's your material
balances on the mixers.
And I'm going to give
you different algebraic
constraints.
So this is a problem now where
we say measure c1 and c3.
And we want to try
to predict c2 and c4.
Can you figure out
the differential index
of this DAE system?
Feel free to talk to each other.
It's OK.
OK, the differential index is 1.
This one's the easy one right?
Just take one derivative
of the algebraic equations.
Now, I've got dc2 dt,
dc4 dt, dc1 dt, dc3 dt.
Differential index of 1 is
easy to solve as an ODE IVP.
This is the natural
problem, too.
It's useful to think about
the inputs c1, c3 and asking
about what the outputs are.
Physically, this problem
seems easier in nature.
OK let's change it now.
Same problem.
But let's change the
algebraic constraints.
Now, the algebraic constraint
is I measure c3 and c4,
And I want to predict c1 and c2.
What's the differential
index here?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Why was this a
differential index of 1
if you have to take a derivative
for c1 and this equation?
PROFESSOR: Oh, good question.
I'm going to push the slide
back, and I apologize for this.
And I'll go back for it.
So the question was why was
this differential index one
if I had to take a derivative
of both this equation
and that equation.
So the way to think
about this conceptually
is I took a derivative of
the algebraic equations,
the set of algebraic equations.
It was one time derivative
of a vector valued function.
I can see where the
ambiguity is there.
So it's important to be clear.
I took one time derivative
over the equations that
prescribe the algebraic states.
That's the distinction.
So this is index
1 because I needed
one time derivative of this
type, dg dt of the entire set.
Here we go.
We're on this one.
Prescribe c3.
Prescribe c4.
What is the
differential index now?
What do you think?
We got an answer?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
I hear 2.
I hear 3.
I saw 3 like this.
Almost mistook it for
a 2, but that's 3.
Yes.
It's 3.
Let's see if we can
work through why it's 3.
So I take a derivative of
the algebraic equations,
one derivative.
And after taking
that derivative,
I'll get a differential
equation for one
of the algebraic states.
So c3 is taking care of.
Now, I'm in the hunt for c1.
So I have-- after
that first derivative,
I have an equation
dc4 dt is gamma 2.
And I know dc4 dt,
so I drop that in,
and I get an algebraic equation
relating the derivative
of gamma 2 to c2, c3, and c4.
This new algebraic equation.
This is like the g1
that I prescribed
in the generic scene.
I take a derivative of it again
because I'm in the hunt for c1.
So I take the derivative
of this new equation,
and I'll get a derivative
of c2, a derivative of c3,
and a derivative of c4.
And I know all those.
I know the derivative of c2.
I know the derivative of c4.
And I know the derivative of
c3 from the previous level
in the hierarchy.
I figured that out already.
So it's two derivatives.
Still hasn't gotten me
a time derivative of c1.
But when I make
those substitutions,
I'll get an algebraic
equation in terms of c1.
And I can take one
more derivative,
and that will give me a dc1 dt.
And I'll have an od
for c1, c2, c3, and c4.
So its differential index 3.
It makes sense sort of.
I'm taking a measurement of an
output way down the line here.
And I'm trying to predict
what the input was
in the first place.
It's easy to
imagine that there's
a huge amount of sensitivity
in that calculation.
Here's another one.
What's the differential
index here?
I'm now prescribing
c1 and c2, and I
want you to tell me c3 and c4.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Oh, good.
Somebody noticed early on.
So you say it's not possible.
Right.
Why isn't it possible?
AUDIENCE: You take
derivatives of both of those--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
you can't isolate c3--
PROFESSOR: Right.
We'll never be able to isolate
a derivative of c3 here.
There's actually there's
something wrong physically
with this problem.
Yes, somehow I'm supposed
to measure c1 and c2
and use that to
predict c3 and c4.
I don't know c4,
and c3 is an input.
I don't know it either.
How do I figure out an input
when I don't know the output?
It's impossible.
So this model is flawed.
We can formulate any
model we want, pick
any set of these variables
to prescribe algebraically,
but not all of them are going to
admit solutions or make sense.
There's no number of
derivatives that's
going to give us a
closed system of ODEs.
This again comes
back to the point
that really DAEs is all
about model formulation.
There are lots of good
numerical methods.
They work like the numerical
methods for ODE IVPs.
What's important is getting
consistent models down,
models that, for
example, have solutions.
You might feed this
to a DAE solver
and get nonsense because I
can almost freely prescribe
what c3 is, and I'll
get some answer for c4.
Any c3 can give
me an answer here.
So who knows whether this
numerical solver is sensitive
or not to this particular
pathology in the problem
we've written down.
We got to speed up just a little
bit, and I'm sorry for that.
So we looked at index 1.
That was stirred tank 1.
Index 2, that was
stirred tank 2.
Index 3, that was
stirred tank 3.
And one thing we saw
when we looked at them
was this index 1 solution.
It had pieces that
were proportional
to this forcing function
gamma, this prescribed function
in our system of equations and
proportional to its derivative.
So if gamma is jumping around,
well, c1 will jump around.
C2 is going to be smoothed
out version of gamma
because it depends
on its integral.
It's not very sensitive,
kind of like an ODE IVP.
Doesn't really show any more
sensitivity than an ODE IVP
does.
The dynamics are different
for index 2, though.
When we look at the
solution of the index 2 DAE,
we found c2 goes like gamma,
but c1 has to go like gamma dot.
So that's pretty sensitive if
you're making a measurement,
and there's noise
in the measurement.
How do you even know
what this derivative is?
So c1 is wildly bouncing around.
Our prediction of
what c1 is is--
it's not going to be very good.
Our solution of DAE example
3 when it told us c1
was related to the
second derivative
of the forcing function,
c2 to the first and c3
was proportional to
the forcing function.
So this is hugely
sensitive to changes
in the forcing function.
So the higher the index goes,
the greater the sensitivity
to perturbations in the system.
Here's another simple example.
You have all that data,
actually, in your paper,
so I won't ask you to do this
one given our time constraints.
But here's-- mechanical systems
that have constraints are often
indexed 3 DAEs it turns out.
You can show this one
is an index 3 DAE.
This is the case of a pendulum
swinging back and forth.
So it's a-- change in
position is its velocity.
Its acceleration
balances gravity,
and there's some arm that
holds the pendulum in place.
We can imagine that that
arm has some tension in it.
It acts like a spring
with a spring constant
that changes in time in order
to hold the pendulum at a fixed
distance from its center.
So two differential equations,
one algebraic equation.
This is a differential
algebraic equation.
You can imagine lots
of mechanical systems
work in exactly this way.
They can only move
along prescribed paths.
They're constrained in how
far they can stretch or go.
I don't know.
If you're trying to design
a robot or something,
DAEs are pretty important, and
they're all of index 3 type
it turns out.
So differential variables
here are x and v,
and the algebraic variable
is the spring constant, k,
which has got to adjust
dynamically in time in order
to--
got to get away
from the speaker--
adjust dynamically
in time in order
to provide just the right
stiffness to keep this going
around on a circular orbit.
So when-- let's suppose I
start with my pendulum down,
and it's not moving,
then this has
to be just stiff enough
to balance gravity.
The pendulum is 90 degrees,
and it's not moving.
I don't need any stiffness.
K and just be 0.
There's no forces to balance.
The pendulum is
swinging around, and I
have to be stiff enough
to balance gravity
where I am and also counteract
any sort of centripetal
[? acceleration. ?]
So this k has
got to be wildly fluctuating.
If I was trying to
control that k somehow
to give this system these
particular dynamics,
you might imagine it's
very difficult to do.
So there's your
differential variables.
Here's your algebraic variable.
You take a derivative
of this equation,
you'll get a constraint
that tells you
the velocity is orthogonal
to the position.
Of course it is.
I'm on a circular trajectory.
You take a derivative
of this equation
now, this algebraic equation.
You'll get another
constraint that gives you
some relationship
between k, x, and v
but not a differential
equation for k.
Take another derivative of
this algebraic equation,
and you'll get a
differential equation for k.
So in principle, I could
formulate a system of ODEs
with dk dt, dx dt, dv dt
will be equivalent to this.
It took three derivatives
to do this, though.
So it's an incredibly
sensitive system.
It's index 3 in nature.
So if I transform
to this equivalent
set of ODEs, the problem--
we discussed this earlier--
is that the solutions may
drift away from the
initial set of constraints.
The solutions also
need the right sort
of initial conditions.
Here I know that at time
0, c3 better be gamma 0.
I know that in the actual
solution to this problem,
c3 dot was gamma dot.
So at time 0, c2 better
be gamma dot of 0.
And at time 0, c1 better
be gamma dot dot of 0.
And if it's not,
then there's going
to be some step jump or
some strange behavior
in the solution to
this ODE system.
So I have to choose the right
sort of initial conditions.
If those initial conditions
aren't chosen correctly,
then I'm not going to
get the right solution.
I won't be constrained to the
manifold of solutions that's
given by the original DAE.
So here's some things
you need to know.
Index 1, semi-explicit DAEs can
be safely handled in MATLAB.
So ode15s, ode23t,
they have the ability
to take an input of mass matrix.
We discussed mass
matrix last time.
And a right hand side to
the system of equations
in f of x and t
and solve it just
like all the other solvers,
all the other ODE IVP
solvers in MATLAB.
If it's not index 1,
MATLAB can catch it.
So it'll try to look at the
Jacobian of f with respect
to the variables
and the mass matrix
and to infer from that what
the differential index is.
And it will tell
you often times--
I think depends which
package you're using.
But if you're using certain
packages, it'll tell you.
It's not index 1oe--
DAE.
We can't handle this.
The methods built into
it aren't suitable.
For generic DAEs, there
are specific DAE solvers.
So something like
SUNDIALS or DAEPACK--
this is Professor Barton's
software actually--
that are designed to handle
DAEs up to some certain index
instead.
They're built to reliably
solve these problems.
So we have robots with
constraints on them.
We solve all sorts of problems
for chemical process systems
that are of higher index.
And the way we do it is using
specific numerical methods.
They're based on the
same sorts of schemes,
backwards difference
formulas, but careful analysis
of the equations, which are
in general unstructured,
the software doesn't
know beforehand
what those equations look like,
but a careful analysis of them
in order to figure out how
to minimize numerical errors
and stay on the correct
solution manifold.
As input to these,
though, we have
to give initial conditions.
So that's going to be the last
thing that we talk about here.
And those initial
conditions have
to be prescribed what
we call consistently,
or we can get numerical errors,
or the software can just
quit and throw an
error, or it can run off
on some other solution manifold
that doesn't look anything
like the solution we're after.
The pendulum is an interesting
example to think about.
So you might say,
well, what do I want
to know about this pendulum.
Maybe I want to know
where it started initially
and what its velocity
initially was.
Can I prescribe the initial
position of the pendulum
arbitrarily?
What do you think yes or no?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Why not?
Why no?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good, yes.
We know it's got a
fixed arm length.
Can't pick any position.
That's not going to work.
It's got to satisfy that
algebraic constraint.
Can I specify its
velocity arbitrarily?
What you think?
Can I give it any initial
velocity that mass
at the end of the pendulum?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: No.
Why not?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
PROFESSOR: Well,
explain that to me,
though, because I had
equations for the velocity
and for that
acceleration and then
an equation that told me that
the length of this moment arm
had a certain length
associated with it.
So why does that
constrain the velocity?
You're right.
It does.
I'm not saying you're wrong.
You're right, but why?
Those initial three
equations don't tell me
anything about the initial
velocity was supposed to be.
We know something
about the trajectory
this is supposed to
sweep out, though.
It's supposed to sweep
out a circular trajectory.
And the velocity in
that circular trajectory
is always going to be
orthogonal to the moment time.
And that equation
actually-- it appeared.
It appeared when we took a
derivative of the constraint.
So this was a hidden constraint.
It's secret.
You didn't know it was there
until you took a derivative,
and you tried to go and figure
out what index this was.
Then you discovered velocity
and position or orthogonal
to each other.
My initial condition
should respect that.
How can they not?
The initial conditions
have to be a solution
to the equations as well.
So now can the initial stiffness
be specified arbitrarily?
No.
There was also an
algebraic equation
that popped up at some
point right here when
I took the second
derivative, which tells me
how the stiffness
has to be related
to position and velocities.
It's also hidden inside
the structure of this DAE.
So this-- again goes
to model formulation,
what are the initial conditions
that I have to prescribe?
If I prescribe the
right ones, I'll
get a solution that matches
the dynamics of the problem I
was actually interested in.
If I prescribe them
incorrectly, who
knows what's going to result?
We can't really predict.
Depends on the solver
we're working with.
Here's a formal
way to think of it.
So usually in an
initial value problem,
usually we want to know what's--
for these first
order difference--
differential equations, what's
the initial value of the state,
and what's the initial
value of its derivative.
That completely specifies what's
going on at the beginning.
One way to think
about these problems
is I've got this equation
that I want to solve.
I could think in some
sense that x and x dot
are independent of each other.
I could always write this is
something like an equation
for f of x and z.
And then I could add
some extra information
that tells me actually
x dot is the same as z.
So initially, I would like to
know the values of x and z,
that z is x dot.
So I'd like to know initially
the values of x dot and x.
And tell me where
I start, and these
need to be consistent with
the initial value problem
that I specified.
If I'm doing an index
0, an ODE IVP, at least
be consistent with this.
So if you tell me
x naught, that I
should put x into this
equation, then that
should tell me what x dot is.
If you tell me x dot, then
I should solve my governing
equation for x naught.
You could tell me some equation
that relates x naught and x
dot initially, and
now I got to solve
this equation in conjunction
with my governing equation
to determine these--
this set of values.
I'd like to know both of
these things initially.
The fully-implicit DAE, I
really have two n unknowns here.
I don't know x, and
I don't know x dot.
And I've only got n
equations for those.
So apparently there's n degrees
of freedom to specify here.
I need n more
equations to say what
those initial conditions are.
And these hidden constraints
I point out actually
reduce the number of
degrees of freedom.
The fact that these are
not index 0 problems
but have a finite index will
introduce extra constraints
that reduce the number
of degrees of freedom
or the number of other
equations I can use to specify
those initial conditions.
Does that make sense?
Let me give you some examples,
and then I'll let you go.
So if I have a problem that
has separate differential
states and algebraic
states, this
is like f of x dot x and y and
t equal 0, the set of things
that I need to specify--
I need the initial derivative
of the differential state,
the initial value of
the differential state,
and the initial value
of the algebraic state.
I'd actually need to know the
initial value of the derivative
of the algebraic
state here because I
don't need that to satisfy
this initial equation.
Let's look at a
couple of examples.
So here's stirred
tank example 1.
I converted to a system of
ODEs by taking the derivative
of equation 2 here.
So here's my two ODEs.
I got to look back at
my initial equations
and see how do they constrain
the initial conditions.
So equation 2 tells me
that c1 initially better
be gamma initially.
Otherwise, my initial
condition doesn't
satisfy the governing equations
of the model that I wrote down.
Equation 1 tells me that
the derivative of c2
initially better be related
to the derivative of c1
and the derivative of n--
I'm sorry to the value of c1
and the value of c2 initially.
This third equation that I came
up with, it doesn't constrain.
It's a derivative of one of the
original algebraic variables,
so it doesn't constrain
that original set of--
I need to know the initial
condition on the differential
variables, the derivative of
the differential variables,
and the algebraic variables.
This only tells me something
about the derivative
of this algebraic variables.
This equation doesn't give
me any other constraints.
So I just got a free
variable that I can specify.
One more equation.
It can be whatever I want.
So maybe I say c2
of 0c0, or maybe I
say there's some relationship
between c1 of 0 and c2 0.
Or maybe I say that c2
of 0 and c2 prime of 0
are related in some way.
Whatever I specify,
I have a system
of three equations for three
unknowns, c1 of 0, c2 dot of 0,
and c2 of 0.
I need to have a unique
solution to that.
Otherwise, there's going to be a
problem solving for it in time,
the system of equations.
So I have to choose this one
consistent with these other
ones, but beyond that I'm OK.
Here's stirred tank example 2.
So I take a derivative
of equation 2,
and that gives me a differential
equation for dc2 dt.
Actually, I already
had one of those,
so I substitute
for dc2 dt, and I
take another derivative to get
a differential equation for c1.
And let's ask about
the initial conditions.
So the initial algebraic
equation, it constrained dc2--
it constrained c2.
It said c2 of 0
has to be gamma 0.
The initial differential
equation told me that c1 of 0
had to be equal to c2 of 0
plus v over q, c2 dot of 0.
Remember, I need three equations
to specify c2 of 0, c1 of 0,
c2 dot of 0.
I actually can't
specify c2 dot of 0
freely because in the process
of deriving this differential
equation here so that I
had dc1 dt and dc2 dt,
I introduced a constraint
on the derivatives of c2.
And this tells me that c2 dot
of 0 has to be gamma dot of 0.
There are no free
variables to specify.
There's three equations.
Two of them come from the
initial system of DAEs,
and the third one is related
to this extra equation that
popped up as we tried
to define the index.
It's an implicit
constraint on the problem.
Does that make sense?
I can't specify
these things freely.
They're specified by the
signal that I measured gamma.
There are two
examples here that you
should be able to work through.
One is an index 2 example,
and one is an index 1 example.
We're not going to have
time to go over them.
Sorry for that.
But they work the same way.
So convert to a system of ODEs,
ask what initial conditions
will satisfy the initial
constraints and were there
any other--
were there any other
constraining equations
that popped up?
So if you work through this
example, you'll find out
there was a hidden strength that
either the initial derivatives
of c1 and c2 sum
together have to be 0
or equivalently the
initial value of c3
had to be equal to 0.
You can take this
constraint in either place.
Maybe you want to
take both of them
to make sure that
it's always satisfied,
that there is no numerical
error that drives you off
of this constraint.
It's OK to have these
things over constrained.
It's just not OK to have
them under constrained.
And you'll find out
that while there
were five things I could pick,
the derivatives, and the values
of c1 and c2, and then
the algebraic variable c3
initially.
So there are only four
constraints-- for equations
here for the initial conditions.
I get to pick one more.
I can get it however I want.
Just has to be
consistent with these.
There's one more example.
Again, should work
through these on your own.
But you do the same thing.
Convert to a system of ODEs.
You'll find out that
when you do this,
you'll get a differential
equation for c3.
It didn't introduce
any new constraints
on c1 dot, c2 dot,
or c1, c2, and c3.
So you just need to satisfy--
your initial conditions have
to satisfy the
initial equations,
and you can put in two
more conditions, whatever
you want them to be.
Add five unknowns and
only three equations
for the initial conditions.
And that's it.
So thank you very much.